[Music]
hey Marvel fans Ryan pentoculus aka
agent damn here and I'm Josh Thole and
we are at the red carpet world premiere
of Marvel Studios Avengers endgame
having a lot of fun we've done a bunch
of stuff for the live stream already but
we're here to do a couple of interviews
for this weekend Marvel I can't wait
we're gonna talk to some amazing people
and it's gonna be a wild ride
alright check them out Rob Liefeld we're
here at the Marvel Studios Avengers end
game premiere how you feel and I'm super
psyched I have not been this super
psyched when you're running around the
house on Easter Sunday going and yeah
you know you know and your family's like
can we just get dad out of the house my
son and I have been yelling in game four
days four days how does this night feel
for you
overwhelming I can't believe sometimes I
pinch myself just to make sure that this
is not a dream and I'm not standing here
and pretend talking to you but this is
actually happening and that it's
happening and I can finally talk about
this movie because I am so excited for
everybody to see it if you could
encapsulate the entire 11 years in one
word what would it be thrilling what is
it like to be in the sort of the
creative meetings around this how much
do you know about this film there is as
we're going along a lot of crosstalk
because the movies do speak to each
other in various ways and and so you
know as we were writing ant-man and wasp
long before we shot it I knew the events
of infinity war and they were sort of
crucial to how we position our movie but
it's tricky man because you get excited
as a fan and you know you want to share
with someone and you can't until after a
Friday yeah we'll get there what gets
you into the mindset to craft the music
for this film this has so much Marvel
historical context this is a monumental
effort from everyone involved it's the
culmination truly of 22 films in 11
years
what is this like for you and your
family how much fun is this to see your
father's work celebrated in such a way
it's just incredible because you know my
father would just be I mean I don't
think he could possibly believe it he
saw every comic book he ever drew as a
storyboard for a movie so if he ever you
know if he could see this on screen he
would just be totally awed totally awed
I'm sure to like see all these
characters that you spent like your
childhood loving coming to life and you
get a second bite at that Apple it's
very rare that something ever comes
around again twice I got all the joy I
should have gotten out of these
characters a long time ago and then
thanks to Kevin Feige and these geniuses
at Marvel Studios I get to do it again
every premiere feels like a a wonderful
achievement but up to this point they've
all been steps towards the grander story
this is the completion of the grander
story and and I'm very excited to unveil
it to the world one of the reasons we
wanted to bring 22 movies to a
conclusion with it with an end game is
so that we could have a new beginning
because great stories have endings great
stories have new beginnings but the
focus now being on this end game and and
doing justice not just to everything
that started with Jon Favreau and rapine
jr. but doing justice to everything
start with Jack Kirby and Stan Lee and
all the artists and writers that grew
and evolved all these characters leading
to this moment
[Music]
we have Victoria loans are one of the
main architects that have crafted this
beautiful universe 11 years 21 movies
what does this night mean for you you
know I don't think it's real yet I think
if you ask me this at midnight tonight I
might be able to give you an answer it's
just like when you look around and you
look what we have created then you turn
around and you realize wow and then you
see the movie and you go wow it's a lot
of humility and gratefulness that I feel
I remember the first meeting with them
with Robert and who would have known
that would be this this is craziness do
you have a favorite moment from Marvel
Studios Ironman when you were on set
Robert wanted to take some time off
while we were filming and he goes you
know Sean come on let's take a walk and
I looked at Robert and I said you know
Robert forever and ever you're gonna be
Iron Man and he said I hope so I said no
no III I think so because you know we
had a great feel after three weeks of
shoot it was like something special was
happening all right Josh it's done John
we've talked to so many amazing people
the purple carpet it's not even red the
purple carpet was so much fun exciting
this is your first time doing these how
do you feel I am stunned the amount of
people and love and and the feelings
that so many people are feeling it's
it's such a big premiere he's good to
explode good explode Josh I got to get
you into the movie we're gonna go see
Marvel Studios Avengers end game right
now I know you will too I'll talk to you
again soon I'm Ryan I'm Josh this is
Marvel your universe
you